a
[Música]
según el último informe de la unicef
sobre venezuela la pandemia del cobi 19
afectó el derecho a la educación de
aproximadamente 79 millones de
estudiantes como resultado del cierre de
escuelas la educación virtual no ha dado
garantías a la continuidad del
aprendizaje aunque no existen cifras
oficiales la asociación de institutos
educativos privados maneja que un 25 por
ciento de los alumnos de los centros
educativos públicos y un 5% de los
privados se han quedado por fuera del
sistema online debido a la crisis de
servicios públicos que vive el país los
alumnos no cuentan con las herramientas
necesarias para cumplir con las clases
virtuales en venezuela- de constante
fallas de electricidad también la
conectividad y velocidad del internet
son las más bajas de américa latina' los
hogares pobres estudiantes tampoco
cuentan con equipos como computadora
tablet o teléfonos inteligentes para que
reciban clases a esta situación se debe
suma que muchos docentes venezolanos del
sector público que ganan menos de un
dólar al mes han abandonado su puestos
de trabajo para dedicarse a actividades
que den mejores ingresos
[Música]
en colombia el sector educativo más
afectado por la pandemia ha sido el
sector público y es en este en el que se
educa el 80 por ciento de los
estudiantes del país de acuerdo con la
universidad javeriana la virtualidad ha
acentuado las diferencias entre los
centros privados y los públicos según
esta entidad al inicio de la pandemia en
un 96% de los municipios del país menos
de la mitad de los estudiantes contaba
con las herramientas tecnológicas
necesarias para acceder a la educación
virtual y un 48 por ciento de los
centros educativos no contaba con
docentes capacitados para impartir
clases virtuales una cifra que se reduce
al 12% cuando se trata de centros
privados según el ministerio de
educación unos 102 mil niños abandonaron
sus estudios durante el año pasado entre
marzo y octubre una cifra sin embargo
que la confederación de padres de
familia multiplicada hasta por seis en
este momento el país se encuentra en una
etapa de reapertura parcial de los
centros educativos
con una modalidad que combina las clases
virtuales y las presenciales sin embargo
la cantidad de centros en esta modalidad
depende de cada región
[Música]
en uruguay debido al aumento de casos de
kobe 19 se suspendieron las clases
presenciales y las autoridades analizan
extender la virtualidad uruguay cuenta
del 2007 con un programa de herramientas
digitales de educación denominado plan
ceibal por el cual el 95 por ciento de
los estudiantes de primaria y secundaria
tienen una tablet laptop y herramientas
educativas sin embargo este programa no
contemplaba la currícula total de los
estudiantes otro problema que se debió
enfrentar fue el acceso gratuito a la
internet el gobierno está trabajando un
acuerdo con las telefónicas privadas el
programa también incluye teleconferencia
es lo cual ha sido muy utilizado por
docentes y estudiantes analistas
indicaron que en el 2020 el al nivel
académico se pudo mantener debido a este
plan ceibal y señalan que es el problema
la capacidad de las familias para apoyar
la educación virtual y no el acceso a
las mismas
[Música]